je vous emmène tout de suite au quartier
général de la sûreté du québec que vous
reconnaissez très certainement le maire
de montréal michael applebaum qui quitte
en ce moment même ses images de vous
parviendrez rect de là bas qui quitte
donc le quartier général alors constaté
les journalistes ont tant bien que mal
de tenter d'arracher quelques mots
quelques commentaires à monsieur
applebaum à la suite de son arrestation
ce matin par des membres de l'upac ce un
probant qui rapidement s'est engouffrée
à l'intérieur de son véhicule d'ailleurs
vous aurez remarqué que les policiers
avaient demandé aux journalistes
présents quartier général de s'éloigner
pour permettre un monsieur important de
pouvoir valider les lieux plus
facilement possible sans doute ce qui
n'empêche pas lire nombreux journalistes
présents sur place caméraman et
photographe de tenter de prendre
quelques images de monsieur adama je
peux membres qui est sur la sellette
depuis très tôt ce matin qui a été
appréhendée comme je vous le disais par
les policiers de la sûreté du québec qui
va devoir répondre à plusieurs chefs
d'accusation et il ya parmi ces
accusations des choses très graves on
accuse de complot de fraude envers le
gouvernement d' abus de confiance et
d'actes de corruption dans les affaires
municipales de tamar